[Musique]
après la découverte de gisement gazier
et pétrolier entre 2014 et 2015 au large
de ses côtes et de la Mauritanie le
Sénégal est récemment devenu membre du
gaz exporting country forum le GCF l'OPE
du gaz
il a rejoint le club des pays
producteurs comme la Russie le Qatar le
Nigéria
le gisement de grandes tortue à minimes
GTA doit débuter sa production d'ici fin
elle représentera pour débuter 2,5
millions de tonnes de gaz naturel
liquéfié GNL chaque année une production
largement inférieure à celle du Nigéria
qui a les plus grosses réserves du
continent africain le Qatar premier
producteur mondial produit environ 77
millions de tonnes de GNL par an d'ici
2030 le Sénégal prévoit de produire
jusqu'à 10 millions de tonnes de GNL par
an 10 millions de tonnes c'est quand
même extrêmement significatif au niveau
du Sénégal ça va vraiment être un
secteur économique très important
surtout que ils vont commencer la
production pétrolière la même année il
va y avoir les deux arrivées d'argent
qui vont être compétentes et qui vont
faire en sorte que l'économie du pays va
être
bouleversée ce qui veut pas forcément
dire que ça sera un producteur
extrêmement important au niveau mondial
mais ça au niveau régional et au niveau
continental il baiseront
dans un premier temps la majeure partie
du gaz sera liquéfié exportée vers le
marché européen pour générer des revenus
financiers
des pays comme l'Allemagne ou la Pologne
qui cherchent à s'affranchir du gaz
russe ont manifesté leur intérêt pour le
gaz du Sénégal
les revenus du gaz doivent permettre de
financer les projets phares du plan
Sénégal émergent selon le gouvernement
sénégalais
certains observateurs pensent que les
rentes doivent servir à développer les
énergies renouvelables comme le solaire
l'éolien ou l'hydraulique
dans un second temps une partie de la
production servira au gaz to power
l'utilisation du gaz pour alimenter les
centrales électriques locales
auquel s'efface le Sénégal c'est
justement
l'autonomie énergétique
nous dépendons énormément de
l'importation des hydrocarbures qui
alimentent notre secteur énergétique et
donc je pense que c'est une bonne idée
d'utiliser la part dédiée à l'état du
Sénégal et un peu trop simple pour
davantage réduire ces indépendance que
vous allez remplacer un certain nombre
de centrale qui fonctionnait au diesel
au fioul lourd et à d'autres
hydrocarbures extrêmement polluants par
du gaz qui est moins polluant et surtout
qui sera moins cher puisque ça sera un
gaz du Sénégal le gisement de
yakartheranga devrait satisfaire les
besoins en gaz du marché domestique à
partir de 2024
selon l'État sénégalais le gaz destiné
au marché local permettra de baisser les
coûts de production de l'électricité
d'environ 50%
[Musique]
dans de nombreux États notamment en
Afrique la production de gaz et de
pétrole entraîne de manière paradoxale
un appauvrissement du pays en cause la
mauvaise gouvernance des ressources
naturelles si vous n'avez pas de
contre-pouvoir avant l'arrivée de la
production pétrole et gaziaire vous
allez avoir un développement extrêmement
inégalitaire parce que justement il va y
avoir une concentration des richesses
dans les mains du régiment place
l'avantage du Sénégal c'est qu'on est
dans un cas qui est assez proche de
celui du Ghana avec des gens bien formés
avec une société civile qui existe donc
il y a des chances que la manne soit
mieux répartie parce que la gouvernance
est bien meilleure que pour beaucoup de
pays qui sont venus producteurs c'est
10-15 dernières années en particulier en
Afrique en Afrique centrale l'indice de
gouvernance des ressources naturelles
évalue les politiques et les pratiques
employées par les autorités pour
gouverner les secteurs pétroliers
gaziers et miniers de leur pays
en 2021 la République démocratique du
Congo l'Ouganda ou encore le Maroc ont
obtenu des scores insuffisants faibles
ou défaillants tandis que le Ghana et le
Sénégal font partie des bons élèves